She says you asked her, sir, to enter into an open marriage.
Would you like to take some time to respond to that?
No, but I will.
I think the destructive, vicious, negative nature...
...of much of the news media makes it harder to govern this country,...
...harder to attract decent people to run for public office.
And I am appalled that you would begin a presidential debate on a topic like that.
Back in 1967, your father set a groundbreaking,...
...what was then a groundbreaking standard, in American politics.
He released his tax returns.
He released them for not one year, but for 12 years.
Will you follow your father's example?
Maybe.
Grandiosity has never been a problem with Newt Gingrich; he handles it very, very well.
You're right. I think grandiose thoughts.
This is a grandiose country of big people doing big things.
And we need leadership prepared to take on big projects.
If there's one thing, just one thing in this campaign you could do over, what would it be?
Well, I would have worked to get 25 more votes in Iowa that's for sure.
Why is President Obama for young people being allowed to stay on their parents' insurance until 26?
Because he can't get any jobs for them to go out and buy their own insurance.
I have an offer to the parents of America:...
...elect us and your kids will be able to move out because they'll have work.